as you said when you hacked the game
donkey kong we're not trying to send
some kind of right this wasn't a this is
trying but like a lot in the process
right so after this had happened and I
this like a pouring of opinion and
everything on the YouTube channel and
and realizing what my daughter is gonna
be facing as she grows up now I've got
this thought of like how can I and just
my my daily development life and
everything else how do I apply what I've
learned in this process to the next
thing or the next game we do in the next
hack or whatever right and so I'm in the
middle of trying to figure that out I
don't really have an answer for that
I've got a few emails I've kind of
pushed up to the top from people who are
really touching stories about how games
affected their lives and how it
continues to video games can actually
help people and there's a good way to do
this and it's not something you're Scott
thursday i'm gonna make a game to help
people like you know a gallows like you
know brain age stuff and i think that
not that kind of approach there's
something even more culturally something
that's much deeper that you can do with
a game that film can't provide books
can't provide and so I'm exploring that
right now and i have a few test cases
that kind of came my way because of this
that i really want okay to bring this to
ya i think i think that like trying to
change somebody trying to change
somebody's life is not something that
I'm like personally comfortable with
it's like whoa dude it's her own life
when you try too hard that pushes people
away exactly yeah people have been
trying to make games to like teach
people and so on for the longest time
that stuff doesn't work or like games
for girls we're gonna make gains hills
and it doesn't work because like people
don't want this kind of prescriptive
medicine they don't want to be like
preached to the irony is the more
specific you make the thing the more
like specifically personal it is to you
the more kind of widely resident that it
could be in that this is a perfect
example I agree you you you did
something like for your daughter in this
particular situation you never really
intended for it to go wide yeah there's
like all these people are like exactly
it's like because it didn't come from a
place of trying to make a statement or
whatever it ended up like walking into
that and doing what it should have done
which was be itself and and stand for
what his original purpose was it's just
a very difficult line to walk when
you're working on something that's a lot
more personal it's it's like I was
field of dreams like you build it they
will come is I just focus on what's
personal what it's meaningful for you
and like that's gonna be the most
genuine saying that people will be
attracted to I totally agree creation
and creativity I mean that's inherently
a personal yeah Oh comes from a place of
personal motivation and to go in like
you said with a prescriptive thing not
prescriptive in the sense of you know
everyone needs this but prescriptive in
the sense that this is how we're gonna
structure this so as to appeal to X Y or
Z the sincerity is gone and if you're
building a game to be sincere about
something or to make an emotional impact
it's just gonna either be clean
saccharine or completely like the void
of actual just so many examples of that
yes it's just very frustrating and being
in the industry this long and working
for so many different people it's it's
you can get jaded really easily with the
stuff like you always walk into a
meeting with like our Democrat
demographic I have writers like oh kill
me kill me and then also the selling of
the idea and stuff for funding and all
these things it's just like it's such a
soul destroying process but when you get
past that and you feel like you have the
palette now and the the canvas to do
what you need to do that's when it gets
really exciting Greg when we were
talking to you about transistor you said
when you brought it to to Penny Arcade
you said how are we going to describe
this to people yeah licious haven't
played the game because having to log
line this thing that you're pouring all
your time into is just that act of
distillation Rob's it of all of its yeah
are like we didn't like back solve from
the message we didn't like come up with
here's the hook and here are the key
features and then let's build those
instead it's a more organic process of
like build the thing find out what the
actual sort of heart and soul of it is
and and then you know have some people
play it report back to you what they
think is interesting about it then
you're like okay then you have a certain
amount of confidence and what's at the
heart of the game as opposed to just
trying to force it the entire time which
games that are like designed on paper
rather than like fully prototyped and
stuff like that i think they often run
the risk of that prototyping itself is
like a form of hacking maybe I should
take whatever you have to be shaking
throw it together and react to people
the way they're playing a game like I
always fall back on an old quote friday
was Tory with Tommy Mitani you an idea
and he he was a designer of pac-man the
designer pants man and he was
like what is a game designer there's at
a time when don't even really knew what
to how to describe a game designer and
his response was very immediate he was
just like somebody who makes a game that
makes people happy everything I've ever
made and my whole life has always been
that like weather was to make my friends
happy make me happy or whatever yeah and
so when the prototypes coming together
like if nobody's happy in that process
yeah like that that's the worst and so
you you hack whatever you have to do to
hack the happiness in mmm and we're
doing that right now on a project and
it's so rewarding to to hack something
together no matter what it looks like or
anything and somebody when they're
playing it and you see that smile come
up you're like done that we've got that
mark i'm sure people make games to make
people sad or whatever i'm the
palliative emotions but ultimately I
make games to make people happy but it's
really awesome in that regard I don't
see a difference between hacking a game
to make myself happy or somebody else
from a prototype
really good when we got actual game
developers in here isn't it it's not
just you and I just jabbering about
whatever pops our head fake Simpsons
references bootleg Street Fighter oh
yeah Chumlee fireballs Wolfenstein
characters and drag Oh Wolfenstein
characters as Yoshi's unicorns that poop
fire